[Musik]
jetzt einen kurzen nachrichten update
von uns aus der heute redaktion guten
abend zu ihnen halten
es ist ein schwerer rückschlag für das
tübinger unternehmen chorwerk das
eigentlich große hoffnungen gemacht
hatte
auf einen weiteren corona impfstoff in
einer zwischenanalyse ist der
durchgefallen wegen zu geringer
wirksamkeit für die impfkampagne in
deutschland deren teil kovac mal war
sieht das gesundheitsministerium keine
auswirkungen bei kubi somit mehr dazu
enttäuschung beim einstigen
hoffnungsträger 47 wirksamkeit in der
neuen studie sind zu wenig als gründe
werden probleme bei der dosierung und
neue virusvarianten genannt der
impfstoff wird nicht an den biotech oder
moderne impfstoff falls die wirksamkeit
angeht hat an reichen
wir müssen mit der niederlage leben
daraus lernen und das dann besser machen
der bund war vergangenes jahr mit 300
millionen euro pa kurek eingestiegen und
hält an der beteiligung fest in dem
rückschlag bei chur weg sieht das
gesundheitsministerium kein problem und
betont man habe schon gar nicht mehr mit
diesem impfstoff geplant die
impfkampagne laufe unverändert weiter
und das ist auch wichtig sagen experten
die noch stärker ansteckende delta
variante die zuerst in indien entdeckt
wurde verbreitet sich auch in
deutschland es wird ganz sicherlich eine
vierte welle geben die wird auch von
einer delta variante dominiert sein wie
stark sie dann ausfällt das hängt davon
ab wie erfolgreich unsere impfkampagne
über den sommer ist in dieser hamburger
grundschule gibt es den verdacht dass
sich schüler mit der delta variante
angesteckt haben drei klassen sind
vorsichtshalber in quarantäne
die monologe wetzel fordert jetzt
schnell konzepte für den schulbeginn
nach den sommerferien um
ansteckungsquellen bei ungeimpften
schülern zu verhindern
und dann schauen wir uns jetzt die
aktuellen corona zahlen an für
deutschland 1330 neuinfektionen binnen
eines tages meldet das
robert-koch-institut das sind 1857
weniger als vergangenen donnerstag 105
menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
coop 19 binnen 24 stunden
die sieben tage incident sinkt weiter
deutlich auf jetzt 11,6 chaotischen und
planlosen einkauf von masken wirft der
bundesrechnungshof dem
gesundheitsministerium vor in einem
prüfbericht für den haushaltsausschuss
des bundestages steht das
bundesministerium habe zu beginn der
pandemie aufgrund unrealistischer
annahmen mehreren
laden masken zu viel eingekauft die spd
und die opposition fordern aufklärung
gesundheitsminister jens spahn sagt man
habe in einer notlage unkonventionell
handeln müssen herbst 1989 wendezeit in
der ddr es geht um demokratie
meinungsfreiheit freies reisen und auch
um die taten der stasi bürgerrechtler
besetzten damals auch die zentralen des
ddr-geheimdienstes um zu verhindern dass
stasi-unterlagen geschreddert werden
bespitzelte bürger und forscher konnten
die akten fast 30 jahre lang in der
stasi unterlagenbehörde einsehen
die ist ob heute geschichte kathrin
lentner berichtet allein 111 kilometer
stasi akten zeugnisse der ddr-diktatur
sie und die mitarbeiter werden ab heute
in das bundesarchiv integriert die
dokumente werden digitalisiert und
bleiben weiter einzusehen wichtig für
opfer wie peter kolb als er mit 22
jahren in dieses fahrzeug gesteckt wurde
hatte er über 30 stunden verhör hinter
sich und einen missglückten
fluchtversuch tür zugemacht und dann war
es dunkel für mich war das eine nicht
enden wollende fahrt wo man auch alles
registriert ein halbes jahr war peter
kolb im cottbuser gefängnis inhaftiert
eine der größten politischen
haftanstalten der ddr viele leiten auch
heute noch unter den folgen der haft
ansprechpartnerin für peter kolb und
menschen die noch auf eine entschädigung
hoffen
ist ab heute die ddr oppositionelle
evelyn zupke erste sed-opfer beauftragte
also ich würde mir wünschen dass kein
opfer mehr an bürokratie scheitern muss
oder angesagt anfragen der
gesundheitlichen begutachtung die oft
ganz schnell wieder opfer sind weil
diese prozesse oft re traumatisieren
peter kolba vor erst vor zwei jahren aus
stasi-akten dass sein eigener bruder die
familie bespitzelte es muss auf diese
zweite diktatur auf deutschem boden
hingewiesen werden und schüler sollen ja
auch in unserem demokratischen umfeld ja
demokratie zu schätzen wissen heute
arbeitet er als historiker in seinem
einstigen gefängnis dem
menschenrechtszentrum cottbus alle akten
über seine familie hat er längst noch
nicht gelesen
30 jahre deutsch polnischen
nachbarschaftsvertrag bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier war zu diesem
anlass heute in warschau polens
präsident andré du da empfängt ihn mit
militärischen ehren
steinmeier nannte die beziehungen der
länder eine große europäische
erfolgsgeschichte von duda kamen auch
kritische worte deutschland müsse noch
mehr für die aussöhnung tun so jetzt in
der sendung noch die aussichten vom
sommerwetter im osten sonnig im westen
erst wolken am nachmittag gefahr von
unwettern durch gewitter mit starkregen
hagel und sturm
das ganze bei 28 bis 37 grad
das war es von uns für den moment vom
gesamten heute team danke für das
interesse und jetzt in allen einen sehr
angenehmen fußballer
[Musik]